البدايه من الاحتجاجات في ايران حيث تواصل
السلطه الايرانيه معاقبه المحتجين وانزلت
عقوبات بالسجن يصل بعضها الى 10 سنوات على
400 محتج في العاصمه ايران لمشاركه في
الاحتجاجات المناهضه للنظام وقال رئيس
قضاه محافظه طهران انه حكم على 160 شخصا
بالسجن لمده
25 سنوات وعلى ثمانين شخصا للسجن من سنتين
الى خمس سنوات وعلى 160 شخصا لمده تصل الى
عامين هذا ويواصل المحتجون الايرانيون في
مختلف المدن والجامعات تحدي قوات
الايرانيه رغم انتشارها المكثف الى جانب
وحده الباسيج ففي مشهد شمال شرقي البلاد
تجمع المحتجون امام المسجد الذي تقام فيه
مراسم تامين الشعب مجيد رضا رحمه ورد الذي
عدمه نظامه مؤخرا رغم اغلاق قوات الامن
لباب المسجد ورفع المحتجون شعارات مدهده
باجراءات نظام ايراني وشهدت مدينه
طب ايران اجراءات امنيه مشدده بعد ما تجمع
الاهالي امام مبنى قائم مقام جوان جود
وطالبوا باطلاق سراح رجل الدين سيف الله
حسين كما استمر تجمعات واضطرابات الطلاب
في مختلف الجامعات الايرانيه
احتجاجا على عمليات الاعدام على الرغم من
مصادره بطاقه الشخصيه والهواتف المحموله
لعدد من الطلبه